we want to help shift the social change
conversation from critics to builders we
want to shift the metaphor of diversity
work in America from melting pot and
Battleground to potluck we want to help
facilitate in the next great chapter of
American religion we think we're done
with the chapter judeo-christian it did
good work in its time it's time to move
into Interfaith America and we want to
convince people that you defeat the
things you do not love by building the
things you do and that that is a
profound opportunity to be able to build
something better it is Holy it is sacred
and we should take that opportunity and
be grateful for it
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to Ford the founder and
president of interfaith America member
of President Obama's inaugural Faith
Council and the author of The phenomenal
new book we need to build Amen to that
field notes for diverse democracy Mr Ebu
Patel welcome Ebu Andrew I can't tell
you how excited I am to be on this
podcast thank you
are you kidding man I'm excited to have
you I mean you've been uh building an
awesome Organization for years and years
helping to cultivate religious diversity
in uh America or not cultivated maybe
cultivate acceptance of it since the
religious diversity has happened without
you
um but I loved your book in part because
you did something that I try to do when
I write um which is tell the truth
including sometimes that when like the
truth is rough
um but uh how did you let's give people
a brief summary of how you came to this
work and and what Interfaith America
does sure so I was an activist in
college uh and that was in that was the
mid-1990s it was another moment of kind
of racial Reckoning uh of of
identity-based politics of uh of social
justice work and I got involved in in
kind of the warp and wolf of that and it
was an exciting moment but the problem
is that that my initiation into activism
was of the anger-based variety and I am
not by Nature an angry person and I
don't think that tearing down the system
is the best way to approach social
change but that was kind of the sector
of activism that I first got caught in
and it was faith-based approaches that
kind of helped bring me out of it and I
found myself after this kind of angry
approach to activism I found myself in
the company of uh of people who were
practicing engaged Buddhism and people
involved in the Catholic Worker movement
and people who spoke of repairing the
world from the Jewish tradition and I
was just really inspired by all of these
diverse faith-based approaches to
changing the world it felt to me like
they loved people more than they hated
the system which was different from the
other activists that I had spent time
with the more that I kind of got
involved in in that kind of work the
more it occurred to me that the
diversity movement that I'd been
involved in in college paid no attention
to religion although religion inspired
all of this really profound social
change work and so the notion of what is
it what does it look like to bring
people from different religions together
to act on their shared value of positive
social change that's where the Genesis
of what was once Interfaith Youth Corps
which was the name the organization was
founded under and what turned into what
is now Interfaith America that's that
that's kind of the the Genesis of it oh
so you're in is smiling Muslim and I
visited the ismaili Center in Houston
which I heard anyone who's anywhere near
Houston to check it out because it it's
really beautiful
um and you detail growing up
um in the midwest uh as an Indian Muslim
um and experiences of racism where they
would call you uh Hindu Hindu and then
you talk to your mom about and she's
like we're not Hindu and then you would
say well like I don't think that's where
they're they really intend mom that was
just
um you know racism
um and I was reminded of the way I grew
up so you and I are contemporaries we're
both in our mid late 40s I grew up in an
Upstate New York town that was
predominantly almost exclusively white
um and I got called
uh [ __ ] and ching chong and stuff like
that um fairly regularly
um and you know I I responded to it
differently than you did uh can you
describe your your uh response
so it so the racism that I experienced
growing up was ugly and it hurt and
there were uh many times when the Middle
School lunchroom felt like you know the
fifth circle of hell uh and and one of
the ways that I responded to it was by
trying to be as white as possible which
meant you know back when I was growing
up it meant playing basketball and
listening to a certain kind of music but
also very is that hip-hop or what it was
it was it was glam metal it was glam
metal you know and there are there are
there are kind of so high questions
we're talking about like uh yeah like uh
well back then it was mildly crew and
poison and white snake and then you know
there's there's quality stuff like
Metallica whether or not it's your cup
of tea it's there's you know quality to
the music all right so
um things we had in common uh I I also
tried to play sports in part so I could
um be more American I felt
self-conscious about being this granny
Asian kid
um I also got angry which I got the
sense you did as well there was one very
cutting story you told of I believe it
was your uh younger cousin showed up and
instead of being her protector you kind
of teased her along with other people
and she was like what the heck is going
on and you're just like hey that this
will uh make me seem more of the uh the
normal American crowd if I also am
piling it on and I was like whoa like uh
you know the fact that you admitted I
mean you know obviously it's like we're
kids and people do do things I never had
a cousin show up so I don't know what I
would have done but yeah
but there were things like where you
were reading it
um where uh it it was deeply relatable
and now you're a parent like I am you
have two boys how old are your boys 12
and 15. well a bit older than mine again
earlier start mine are ten and seven
um and and you write in your book about
some of the ways where even now we you
still accommodate various things uh just
to accomplish goals or make life easier
um I remember your father talked about
owning a Subway franchise and someone
was like why Subway and it was like well
you know you can uh just seem American
because when someone comes in and uh you
know they don't really think about who
owns it um but that there was another
episode you related of
um someone not wanting you to make their
sandwich
um they wanted the white sandwich maker
to make the sandwich and you put two and
two together you're like I think it's
because they prefer the white person
make the sandwich
yeah I mean Andrew you read deep into
the book and you're remembering a lot of
the stories and I'm really grateful for
that and and you know one of the things
I'm very blunt about in the book is is
just the ugliness of racism and the way
that that it affected me and also didn't
entirely Define me and and you know I
grew up in a household in which my
parents were very clear our culture is a
privilege our faith is a privilege and
you should look at it as such and
because I think they were immigrants and
because life in America was better than
life elsewhere and I think that it's
important to kind of underscore this
that when people talk about America the
question is what's your reference point
and if your reference point is heaven
America is light years away but if your
reference point is a country where you
can't breathe the air or drink the water
then this nation looks pretty good and
that's not an argument for complacency
that's an argument for possibility what
can you build from here how can you grow
from here so I want to be really
clear-eyed about my experiences of
racism about what my kids now are going
through but also
also clearight about it doesn't have to
it did not Define me it doesn't have to
Define me and I do not only have to
react to that that my my culture is not
about opposing somebody else's hatred of
me my culture is about growing into who
I am meant to be you know as I as I say
to my kids I don't want you to hate
islamophobia more than you love Islam
yeah yeah I mean that that's uh a
beautiful sentiment and obviously spot
on I mean the theme of we need to build
really is about trying to figure out
what the beautiful social order we're
aspiring for is as opposed to uh just
trying to tear things down and you talk
about college of fair amount you relate
your own College experiences so you go
to college you're taught a particular
academic approach to uh racism and
opposing it and I this is one of the
major themes of your book and I can
sense one of the major things you're
concerned about is that that right now
there are a lot of people who are going
to college who are taught to critique
and you yourself were a product of that
but then someone after you were
critiquing an Interfaith Gathering and
you said look this should be much more
young and representative and dynamic and
and involving the Next Generation than
someone put their head on your shoulder
and said you should build that and then
you said okay I will build that that was
uh almost 25 years ago it was almost
June of 1998. yeah that is that's really
the kind of you know that's the creation
myth of of of interfaith America my
organization and it just happens to be
true unlike say the Plymouth Rock myth
you know it you know it happens to be
true that I was uh a light things on
fire activist and I did this at this
Interfaith Gathering and of course I'd
gone to this Gathering because I wanted
to drink from The Well of positive Faith
inspired love people first social change
but I had been so deeply uh kind of
steeped in this approach of raise your
fist and tell other people what they're
doing wrong that when you know it was
one boring panel of senior theologians
after another I stood up raised my fist
and I was like you people are boring
where's the young people where's the
edge where's the energy where's the
dynamism and that's when this woman uh
yolan Trevino approached me and was like
Hey you know it's powerful what you're
putting out there you should build that
and and actually my first thought Andrew
was was
um somebody's calling my bluff you know
and I actually think that that there's a
lot of critique out there that is
deathly afraid of somebody calling their
Bluff and and that is not my critique of
critique it is it is my way of
um
explaining self-righteousness my own and
other peoples that the more
self-righteous somebody is in in
calling out things that are terrible
there's a possibility that there's a
deep fear about being asked to take
responsibility and to be the one in
charge but you know we need to not
we need to not just tell people what's
wrong with the police
we need to tell we need to have people
who can be in charge of Public Safety
like Public Safety is a really important
thing and and telling people what's
wrong with one segment of the public
safety ecosystem without the
corresponding ability to build up that
ecosystem into something that works into
into something that protects people
that's that's the challenge we need to
solve right this is this doesn't mean
the critique isn't valid it just means
it's incomplete
and and you know I have a friend who um
it's a professor uh at an elite East
Coast School in in the Boston area it's
not Harvard
um it's another one and and he said you
know my big fear is that we're teaching
our students who pay 75 000 a year in
tuition room and board we teach them to
critique the things that kids go to
Regional public universities to do
people go to Framingham State to learn
how to become teachers social workers
and nurses and people come to our school
to learn how to critique those folks and
that just seems unfair it just seems
unfair
foreign
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
everyone gets a little bit down
sometimes but the holiday season can be
particularly tough so you know what
maybe you might want to consider doing
is actually using this as an opportunity
to get Professional Therapy online
affordably in the comfort of your own
home you can try it out switch
therapists if you don't like them or
stop if you don't like it but I have a
feeling that you're gonna dig it because
who doesn't want to talk to someone
about themselves as the world's largest
therapy service better helped has
matched 3 million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist at betterhelp.com Yang
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash
[Music]
foreign
so how old were you when Yolanda said to
you hey you should start this yourself
yeah her name is yoland and and uh uh uh
yolan Trevino and actually we just had
our 20th anniversary celebration at of
interfaith America and brought her here
from LA and had a chance to thank her in
person it was really beautiful I was it
was June of 1998 I was 22.
22 year old trying to build something I
know this from experience because I
tried it or tried a version of it a
couple years later
excruciatingly hard yeah so so what the
heck was the first thing you did as a 22
year old when you said okay I guess I
will do this thing so what I did was was
I ran or I was involved in the group of
people running the youth programs of
these adult Interfaith organizations I
had critiqued
so I I want to point out not so much the
irony of that because I was the guy
raising my fist telling people telling
them that they were terrible and boring
and backwards I want to point out the
generosity of those folks right so so
they could have told me to go take a
hike right I was not particularly polite
in my critique instead they were like
hey why don't you come and make this
better why don't you attach your Caboose
to our locomotive and I learned how to
do Interfaith work by helping to run the
youth program at the United religious
initiative and at the parliament of the
world's religions
etc etc and I had a fancy scholarship I
was I was at Oxford on on you know the
the on the on the money left by some old
British colonialist and I used that
money to go around the world and learn
the methodology of interfaith work and
then when I finally finished my PhD
it was just a few months after September
11th I realized that that this the world
kind of needed an organization that
focused on bringing young people
inspired by diverse faiths together in
service and social action projects that
was all about Interfaith bridge building
and actually the world was ready for it
right so Tony Blair paid attention and
Bill Clinton paid attention and we you
know did uh um a project with Queen
Ronnie of Jordan and all kinds of
inspiring things well so you really
meant the moment because after 9 11 uh
there there must have been an incredible
swell of interest in helping people
understand different faiths particularly
Muslim Islam at that time yeah and you
know for for for a long time I played
the friendly Muslim on TV you know I I
would joke that that I was the I was the
Muslim that that didn't scare white
people I was the Muslim Mr Rogers and
the truth Andrew is is that's
actually Who I Am by personality I
wasn't just playing a character on TV
like I I'm generally kind of a
mild-mannered person uh I'm generally a
person I'm genuinely a person who
believes that Islam's core value is
Mercy and that applying that Mercy in
the world through kindness and through
love and hospitality and compassion is
the way to go and I'm also totally
tenacious about organization building
and a huge part of my book we need to
build is about the tenacity of building
an organization and the strategy
involved and so you know I would do
things like even if there's kind of
legit ambient interest in a different
side of Islam or an Interfaith work you
still have to go after it right and so
nobody's going to hand you anything I
remember telling people about Interfaith
youth quarterback when it was named that
and them saying things like we're never
going to fund you you know it's
interesting I'll give you advice when
we're going to fund you I would find out
the conferences those people were going
to be at and I would show up at those
conferences and sit next to them
[Laughter]
but to
communicate my seriousness my tenacity
and that was an ERA you'll remember this
where Ashoka and social entrepreneurship
was celebrated David Bornstein had just
written the book uh um how to change the
world Wendy cop and Teach for America
were were widely celebrated Muhammad
yunus and the Grameen Bank it was kind
of the era of building things right
social change was creating a better way
to do something and then building an
institution to that and and I would say
that I was very much formed in that era
like my initial formation as an activist
was through angry activism in the early
90s and then it was through faith-based
activism uh with you know the Dalai Lama
and tiknot Han and Mother Teresa and
Dorothy Day and the like and then it was
social entrepreneurship and building an
institution to to a better way of doing
things and that's really what I write
about in the book is what does it mean
to to not tell people what they're are
doing wrong you know the goal of social
change is not a more ferocious
Revolution it is a better social order
it's a better way of doing things
whether that's Health Care
or education or arts or racial Equity
what does it mean to create a better way
of doing things and then to build an
institution that can advance that
pattern change that is a really hard
thing to do and self-righteousness will
not get you very far in that endeavor
right what will get you far is long-term
strategy and day-to-day chopping wood
and carrying water yeah you tell stories
about the early years of what became
Interfaith America and you're very blunt
about it someone advised you saying look
you can't be afraid of money but you
can't be crazy for it either and yet you
did what most organizations do and as
someone who's run a non-profit I could
relate very directly to this is that
someone would come and write you a grant
to do certain work and you'd be like
sure you know it's sort of related like
let's go do it it was only later when
you uh
I got certain partners that you started
to say no to more things strip away some
um projects that weren't core to the
vision uh that you then ended up
formulating how many years did it take
for you to get from uh being responsive
to uh having that this firmer Vision
yeah it's a great question uh seven
eight years so the first three or four
years of interfaith Youth Corps was
really building a methodology that was
1998 to 2002 we get our first grant in
2002
it's about seven years of running
entrepreneurial projects some super
exciting things like a youth exchange
with Queen Runya of Jordan and a fate
sacked fellowship with Tony Blair but
you know some totally random things like
the foundation for general for General
Motors gives us a grant to do I don't
know Grassroots work in four or five
cities that's kind of totally random but
it's a grant so we do it the state
department is literally constantly
calling us like on a monthly basis to do
Interfaith youth projects around the
world and so we're in Central Asia and
we're in Eastern Europe and we're in the
Middle East and we're like all over the
place right and we're we don't really
have expertise in this we're just super
entrepreneurial and it's not until 2009
2010 at which point three things happen
one is a consulting firm does a pro bono
strategic plan for us and just basically
says Hey listen you're not making a
long-term difference anywhere you need
to have a you need to have a long time
term strategic goal you need to have a
plan to reach it it's not especially
genius but it is very clarifying so
that's one thing that happens the second
thing that happens is we I get an
appointment on on President Obama's
inaugural Faith Council so there's kind
of a national profile and a level of
seriousness that comes along with that
appointment not to mention like a whole
new set of contacts and you know you're
like literally in the Oval Office in the
Roosevelt room every once in a while and
then finally there's a really serious
philanthropist named David Einhorn who
requests a business plan from us which
of course we're able to do because of of
the uh of the Strategic plan that that
this consulting firm has done for us pro
bono and gives us 10 million dollars and
a lot of that is tenacity and a lot of
it is luck the ability to have a serious
amount of money to be able to then
articulate a five-year vision and to
build a team to go after that vision
foreign
you know one thing I'm thankful for I
wrote a book it's called Ford and it's
now out on paperback I promise you it is
not as boring as a book with democracy
and the title sounds like it's got fun
stories from the presidential will make
you think it'll make you laugh and you
can check it out on paperback or get it
for a friend Happy Holidays forward now
out on paperback
[Music]
oh so here's where I want to dig in a
little bit because it's uh it'll be uh
fun and interesting so first let me say
I I admire you and your work a great
deal and you've helped a lot of people
in this country and I a thousand percent
agree with your critique of the
prevalence of critique as like the the
mode of expression for young people and
academic contexts in particular where
they're just like hey you guys are
screwing this up in this way and that
way uh and then the flip side has to be
like okay like let's actually build
something let's solve the problem let's
do something Solutions oriented
um and you became this
social entrepreneur and you're one of
the most successful social entrepreneurs
in the country but there are all of
these young people that actually want to
follow this General path in terms of
social entrepreneurship you say social
entrepreneurship on a college campus
like all these folks will be like oh
yeah like that that's the dream that's
the ideal
um but of a group of people who set out
to be a social entrepreneur the way that
you did
um it's such a rough road because like
the the marketplace for it uh is wildly
Divergent not terribly well well
resourced the message of the book which
I like I love is like look we need to
build like we need to build things
um another message of the book is like
it's super hard to build which I totally
agree with because I've done it
and it's super hard there is a bit of a
gauntlet you're throwing down
um to say to folks like look guys we
need to actually try and uh create
better institutions uh and not just be
the bomb throwers or the um you know
like the critics
um but that but there's some part of me
that's like man like
um you've already been through like this
journey and in your case you've been
through a journey that's longer and more
um
elevated than just about any of us
um you must have seen a whole host of
people embark on a similar path to
yourself
um at different points in time
um but then their Journey was was very
very different than yours so I think
building a new institution that is
helping to create or Revitalize a sector
is enormously challenging and one has to
have a significant amount of luck
what I've done is challenging and I've
had a significant amount of luck
alhamdulillah praise be to God and what
I would say is it is not a gargantuan
mountain to climb to improve the Civic
activity or area of work that you're
currently involved in if you are the
director of a summer camp at a YMCA
you can think of better ways to run that
summer camp
right if is that summer cramp includes a
wider diversity of people and as you see
how the camp might work for some and not
others there are important changes that
you can Implement that make that a
better summer camp and because you work
within an ecosystem called the YMCA or
the public schools or the Jewish
community centers or whatever it might
be the ways that you improve the
environment in which you are working the
hospital floor the after school program
whatever it might be has a chance of
spreading so what what I've done is a
little bit different right what Muhammad
yunus did with the Grameen Bank what
Wendy Kopp did with with Teach for
America what you Andrew did with Venture
this is a little bit different right
there they are new institutions that are
that don't exist within a vast and
well-developed ecosystem that
effectively have to build both an
institution and an ecosystem but
a lot of what I talk about in we need to
build is the genius of American Civil
Society
Catholic Charities and Habitat for
Humanity and the the world of Methodist
College campuses
etc etc and there is a reasonable chance
that if you're involved in social change
work you are working in one of those
areas improve the thing below your feet
improve the after school program improve
the summer camp improve the way of doing
teacher training improve the way of of
uh of of doing nursing and ask yourself
the question can my Civic innovation in
the classroom on the hospital floor can
this spread
right and so it's what I call a Jane
Jacobs approach to social change rather
than a Robert Moses approach right now
there's an awful lot of talk about
systemic change
I mean I on the one hand
this is not an argument for our systems
being perfect
it's a recognition that like if you're
having a hard time running a six-person
English Department at your you know
at your local college campus maybe you
should be a little bit
like less self-righteous about proposing
vast changes for 100 million person
systems right uh why not take the
approach that Jane Jacobs took to social
change which is ask the question what's
going right locally what are the
environments in which kids play together
in which moms talk to each other etc etc
how can we
create more environments like that as
opposed to the Robert Moses approach
which is I'm going to create this
perfect system in my boardroom with a
group of experts and then we're going to
come out and impose it about everybody
and who cares of Fifth Avenue is going
to run through Washington Square Park
well you know you talked about this
colleague of yours in in college where
you were both
on a board together and he was
determined to get a bench outside of the
the dorm uh and he's like because then
people will have some place to sit and
they hang out and then you looked at
that where like like come on that's not
like what we should be here
be about but it sounds like what you
just described is that like that now uh
older wiser you would be like yeah that
bench is a good idea
I mean this guy's name was Doug and
Andrew I mean you not only did you read
the book but you like actually paid
attention to page after page I'm really
I'm I'm really appreciative of that I'm
really honored by that because look I
just have huge admiration for for what
you've done as I told you like you built
an institution and then you brought that
ethos to the National stage and so I
just stand in admiration of you and and
like I you know it makes my month and
this is my birthday month it makes my
month that you paid such attention to my
book so thank you for that so so you
know the the story the story that you're
you're relating from my book is is uh
University of Illinois uh has Chief
Illini WIC as a mascot and it's a racist
mascot and as I kind of you know
realized that I made it my literally
crusade to like Hound everybody within
eyesight and earshot about the need to
change this mascot and I was you know
very enamorative the idea that that
every minority had a particular stake in
this because
you know this is specifically races
against Native Americans but anybody uh
anybody who who didn't who Who had who
had any kind of skin tone uh uh should
be able to relate to racial oppression
and so I would Hound this guy Doug about
why he you know seemed kind of neutral
to positive on Chief illiniwick and and
he at one you know I would tell him like
you know if if basically some version of
real black people are opposed to chief
of line at wake and and he was a super
mild-mannered guy but at one point he
just lost him he's like stop telling me
what real black people do
wow stop telling and and and if you
think about it like that's
an awful lot of identity-based activism
is
is articulating a standard of
authenticity and telling people that
they're not living up to it
right as opposed to saying huh
um being black or Asian or Latino uh is
a range not just a cultures and
nationalities but it's also a range of
personality types and sexual
orientations and religions and I'm
really curious about the ways that that
manifests in the world I'm going to let
the the amazing Mosaic of black people
Define for me what black is right as
opposed to having having kind of a this
standard of authenticity based on an
imaginary Theology and superimpose that
on people in any case that's what I did
and when he like
lost it on me I think that that was you
know probably the last time I went
around telling people uh what their
authentic self should be and and I take
that it was a gift that he gave me even
though in the moment it burned and and
Doug's approach to social change was
watch what people are doing and watch
where things are healthy and positive
and help that be the case and he was
like you know outside Allen Hall where
where where we were president of Vice
President of the of the dormitory people
like to hang out and they have to sit on
this cold cement and we should have
benches where they can sit and it was a
Jane Jacobs approach to social change
pay attention to people in their natural
habitats and what makes them happy and
help them achieve that and sometimes the
solution is simple and it's actually
better if it's simple it's actually
better if it's simple right if you can
improve people's lives in ways that
don't require major surgery you should
do that
I appreciate his example
one thing I've always believed in is
mattresses I kid you not even when I was
in my 20s and not exactly flush I would
spend a little bit of extra money on a
mattress because I thought you know what
I'm gonna be on this thing for ideally
uh seven or eight hours a day so it
seems kind of important that was a while
ago mattresses have come a long way and
now I am pumped to recommend Helix sleep
it's a premium mattress that provides a
mattress tailored to you and your sleep
preferences 14 unique mattresses go and
take the Helix sleep quiz and find out
what you can do to get the perfect
mattress made for you and if you don't
like it you can return it 100 night
risk-free trial I know it's pretty
bananas don't take my word for it Helix
has been awarded the number one mattress
pick by GQ and Wired Magazine
chiropractors doctors and yours truly
recommended Helix is offering up to 200
dollars off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners go to
Helix sleep.com slash Yang with Helix
sleep better sleep starts now
[Music]
you told one story that again some of
your stories man I was like Wow uh like
uh grateful that you're sharing it he
tell the story by the way I can relate
to so much of this so you're having a
terrible travel day and uh it seems like
you're gonna miss a shuttle that is
going to make you late to get back to
your family your wife's going to to be
uh Furious uh and everyone on this bus
is like a white dude in khakis and
there's a bus driver that has sat them
all and you're afraid You're Gonna Miss
This shuttle and so you say something to
the bus driver about how like I can't
believe that you have uh kicked like the
only non-white dude like off of this
shuttle bus uh and and then she becomes
very afraid and not only that like she
didn't kick me off the bus she just
didn't invite me on the bus first and
and uh I wound up being like last in
line and the reason for that was because
I was looking at my phone
right and and now I had signed up
earlier to take the shuttle and so I
figured that like there was some list
and I'd be called off the list so you
know I wasn't entirely in the wrong but
you could easily have like if if I was
even had an iota of generosity towards
this bus driver she's running late it's
like six in the morning in La you know
she's harried and she's like getting a
group of people on the bus as quickly as
possible and I'm the distracted guy
looking at my phone and she's not
leaving me off the bus she's just like
you know it's your job to get on the bus
right and and and I was thinking to
myself well my name's on some list
somewhere and and that's when I I say
you know oh yeah of course leave the
brown guy off the bus and and this look
of sheer Terror crosses her face like
sheer Terror and she goes inside and I
see her having this this like intense
conversation with the desk clerk and
what she's basically doing is she's like
re-empting whatever I might come my my
possible complaint like she is having
the desk clerk document that you know
she didn't do anything racist or wrong
that you know uh uh uh just in case I
accused her of something and I thought
to myself
I could accuse her of something and in
the era in which we live my accusation
would be taken
probably without that much investigation
and this is a 12 or 15 an hour you know
shuttle bus driver and I am you know a
reasonably high-powered knowledge worker
and as I write in the book I probably
went to school with some of the people
up the chain in the bus company whatever
right and it's
I have power and
telling somebody else that they have
committed a racist act or an act that is
racialized is an accusation with power
and when it is said with somebody with
power
it can lead to bad things and and I knew
that abstractly and I certainly read a
number of stories along those lines
which made me uncomfortable like I was
like this is a terrible thing that's
happening to this museum curator or you
know whatever this uh this janitor at
this at Smith college a famous story
that happened that was in the New York
Times but now I was the person
who was uh in in an indirect way kind of
accusing somebody of of doing something
bad to me and account of my race and
that person was terrified and I'm like I
don't
I don't want to be this guy and I don't
think that every misunderstanding should
be immediately racialized if there is no
evidence of that and that somebody
should be scared to death of losing
their hourly wage as a result of it now
as I write in the book and Andrew as you
as you said earlier there's also
incidents where I've been working in my
parents Subways in which something
happens that is clearly race racist not
just racialized and which I have had to
you know swallow my dignity right and so
both of these things occur in our world
both of these things occur in our world
but but here's what I'm clear about
my experience of racism as a worker in
my parents Subways as a kid
is not neutralized or made better by my
accusation of somebody of a shuttle bus
driver doing doing something racist
towards me if the act that they are
committing is not in fact racist again
the fact that you were able able to own
the
substance of that situation even as
you're relating your your Behavior Uh I
thought was really
um compelling uh and you You observe
that in terms of the relative privilege
or power in American Life a lot of it is
around education uh and that that's
going to be something unfortunately
that's fueling our political
polarization in a particular way
um and that one of your concerns is that
there are people who emphasize different
forms of marginalization even while they
have like a ton of uh educational
privilege and then you're looking around
saying like hey like are you are you
really uh oppressed or
um uh unprivileged relative to the uh
the bus driver or like the person who's
working at the janitorial staff in at
the University yeah I mean Andrew this
is this was the centerpiece of your
campaign and and I'm I don't think I
think it says a lot about you that that
you are focusing entirely I mean in this
podcast even though so much of who you
are about as a presidential candidate
and a mayoral candidate and what the
forward party is about is that the hour
were our economy has fundamentally
shifted and it leaves vast swaths of
people out and we don't have an answer
to that going into the future right and
so I write a little bit about this but
you're I mean I just it should just be
said you're the national leader in this
area and we should all appreciate what
you have done in bringing this
conversation to the fore and and I am
certainly one of those so listen there's
an awful lot of talk and I think it is
it is legit and real about the power
associated with being male with being
white with being quote unquote
able-bodied what about the power
associated with being book smart if
you're book smart in a knowledge economy
boy that is a that is just that is a an
unbelievable amount of power right there
are just things I can't do like I can't
play a guitar as much as I've tried I
can't really shoot baskets I'm not very
good at basketball as much as I tried
can fix a car but I can put together a
speech I have an innate sense of
strategy for an organization I can read
a room right I'm a knowledge worker and
in the the vast majorities of human
Societies in the vast majority of eras
my set of skills would be
not especially important
not you know I can't I can't uh I can't
shoot an arrow I can't ride a horse uh
uh I'm not I'm not a warrior right uh
but in this particular time and place
the small set of things that I'm good at
is King it's highly rewarded it is it is
highly desirable and I just don't
understand why we don't think of it as a
massive privilege to have
book smarts in a knowledge economy
forget access to education all of us
know people who had access to amazing
educations who just weren't book smart
right and so let's be honest about that
and and I think one of the things about
our current discourse is it doesn't
engage in that at all like I'll I'll
never forget I want to relate to two
quick stories I actually forget whether
these are in the book or not I'll tell
you yeah yeah that's amazing so so I was
at uh um uh I was at the small College
in Ohio it was either Oberlin or Kenyan
actually I don't remember exactly which
one and I'm meeting with uh um the
Multicultural student group right the
students of color and I yeah let me say
it I get it like being uh being a Latino
Kid or an African-American kid in like
rural Ohio at a largely wide campus like
I I get that there's a certain amount of
alienation that comes that comes with
that especially if you are from a family
background or an economic background
that that is not that is different from
the ones that most of your classmates
but I'm in this I'm sitting with these
students and there's a lot of talk of of
Oppression and etc etc marginalization
and I'm listening and I turn around and
I and I and I look for a second at the
at the white woman who has set up the
the tea and coffee and cookies
and she is like
looking at these students with her mouth
a gape
and and half of her teeth are missing
and I'm like
what is going on in rural Ohio in 2015
it's
like meth and opioids
and
it would just
I just think it would have been nice
for the students at Oberlin or Kenyon
to just maybe
moderate their con their talk about
being oppressed around
the woman who was making thirteen
dollars an hour
missing hair for teeth setting up
their cookies
you know and and note I am not accusing
anybody of anything no no I'm saying
let's pay attention to the world right
like I remember I tell the story towards
the end of my book
um my first year at Oxford was really
hard I mean it was really emotionally
hard right it was really emotionally
hard and and at the end of that year I
took a trip with my dad to India and
I've got this whole like you know
ideological story of like how Oxford
doesn't like that the Empire has struck
back and there's all these Asian
students at Oxford and like Oxford is
making it deliberately hard for them and
it's this colonial mentality and you
know we the oppressed are rising up and
my dad looks at me and he points to this
leprous beggar child on the street
points to one of them there must be
dozens of them on the street in front of
us points the one and said if you're
oppressed what word do you have for him
yeah
yeah like like if if if
there are not enough mental gymnastics
in the world for me and a leprous beggar
child to belong in the same category and
for that category to be called oppressed
okay so if that's the case right if if
there are actually like billions of
people in the world who live on less
than six dollars a day true
okay and if I can't get through
breakfast without spending six dollars
you know yeah that's true for Me Maybe
maybe I should just
think of myself as something other than
oppressed well what what would it look
like to think of myself as privileged
and to embrace that privilege and to
then ask the question what's the
responsibility that ensues from that
and actually how wonderful is it to
think of oneself as privileged right
that that that and this is partially a
religious thing like God has blessed you
which by the way is like based the the
basic message of the Quran
God has blessed you
now it is your job to be a mercy to
other people that is actually massively
liberating
and it's massively inspiring like why
not walk around the world thinking to
yourself
I am amongst the most privileged people
in human history which for most of us is
objectively true
okay now what can I give to others
that's a very different message than a
lot of people are getting for sure in a
message that I I think is empowering uh
yeah yeah right
you know my son uh my older son was in a
Diversity Program like this intensive
summer Diversity Program
last summer and he comes home one day
and he's like Dad how come only the
white Christian kids get to call
themselves privileged
I'll repeat that right how come only the
white Christian kids get to call
themselves privileged and it just seems
crazy
that that we don't consider people's
cultural identities a privilege
I mean how much time do I spend in my
home telling my kids that their faith
Islam that their Heritage from India
that their opportu that their
citizenship in America is a privilege
and they're supposed to make the most of
it that their family lineage is a
privilege and they're supposed to make
the most of it not in a way that's meant
to be
kind of the anxiety of influence right
but in a way that's meant to be
empowering you have to wind at your back
what will you do with it right it just
seems you know again it it's objectively
true that
we're amongst the most privileged people
in human history it's also beautifully
inspiring for us to embrace that
yeah it it gives us more control of Our
Own Destiny and uh more of an eye for
the impact we can have on the world
um it's certainly a much better way to
approach uh your interactions with
others than uh to what what you said in
the book and there are a lot of quotes I
love in the book but yeah you talked
about how look something can be a useful
lens but you don't want to have it
permanently change your eyesight so that
you you only see uh like like the the
wrongs of the world or like the
weaknesses of institutions
right yeah you know I think I think um
an awful lot of of um of anti-racism
Etc it's a really interesting and useful
critique
I I don't know if it's a great paradigm
and I I definitely don't think it's a
good regime by regime I mean like like
uh something that gets implemented into
the world right but it's really
interesting to constantly be thinking
are are there ways that racism is
affecting this situation
should we should we should we be should
we be attuned to that I think the
question that is absolutely the case we
should always be attuned to the
possibility of that we should watch out
for it we should gather evidence around
it it could be the case that a shuttle
bus driver leaves me out because I'm
Brown
it's not it's not crazy for me to
consider that a possibility but it is
totally unfair for me to accuse somebody
of that without evidence especially when
that accusation is power
right and so that's another critique a
paradigm and a regime and you know we
talk a lot at Interfaith America about
the metaphor of potluck Nation that that
we can't have a diversity Paradigm
that's a Battleground right where
there's only the wicked and the wounded
and and if you're quote unquote dominant
culture you're the wicked and you have
to confess your privilege and then you
go through this strange Alchemy and
you're now an ally but if you're the
wounded then the only opportunity you
have the only script is to constantly
recount your pain in your wounds yeah
that's a form of entrapment right yeah
it's a form of entrapment what we should
be thinking about is we're a potluck and
you're welcoming the distinctive and
delicious convert
contributions of diverse people and
nurturing creative combinations amongst
them that's that's the metaphor uh yeah
you talk in the book about how there are
some bright black uh high school
students who get pushed by well-intended
teachers and mentors to write uh essays
about how pain painful their past is and
how difficult things were uh and uh you
described it as like the singles story
which is like oh there's a single story
that defines groups of people and so if
you're from this group then you should
go along with what these institutions
want and some of these students were
like what if that's not me or what if
that's not my reality or like what if I
would rather just talk about something
else about myself
rather than some painful experiences
I've overcome
right you know the single story was was
a TED Talk uh um
uh by adichie I think I think is the
name of the of the writer and speaker
this notion of
were in in
a particular Paradigm of diversity work
people are handed an invisible script
where some people have to constantly
confess their guilt and other people
have to constantly recount their pain
that just doesn't make sense to me right
like like I my kids are telling me all
the time that they have a set of like
well-meaning adults in their lives who
constantly want to hear about how
terrible their experience with
islamophobia is so my kids have been
called some ugly names in the playground
that is real I'm glad that there are
adults who are attuned to that but what
they get from Islam is infinitely more
important than how they have been heard
by islamophobia and there doesn't seem
to be that many well-meaning adults in
the current ERA interested in that
like that's a problem that's a problem
yes that's really profound uh where I
mean I personally like I try to see how
my kids are growing up
um they don't seem that attuned to uh
racism
um I'm not sure how much has happened to
them as yet uh but to the extent that I
had a lot of teasing or
um uh even bullying uh when I was
growing up and I responded to in various
ways and I became
um you know an angry Asian guy who went
to the gym a little bit too much
but but
they're they're but like putting
yourself in one of these uh buckets uh
and you actually don't use this language
in the book but I love it it's like the
wicked versus the wounded
um you know like most of us are
um much more than uh that that set of
experiences uh and and really one of the
the things I just realized that you did
in your book is that you actually put
yourself in the the shoes of the wicked
occasionally even though you know in
your case uh you know that was often
um uh you know very very much contextual
yeah yeah look I I think that
I I
racism is deforming
I have a close friend
um who developed a really ugly gambling
hat like a habit and
um finally you know went to inpatient
treatment a lot of therapy and when I
talked about like what he discovered
when we talked about what he discovered
um about himself in the course of this
intensive therapy he was like a lot of
my gambling problem was a response to
the racism I experienced as a kid that
is real that is really that is ugly and
it is real and and we should be
clear-eyed about that
and we should be clear about other
things also right that that people are
not only a response to the racism that
they experienced they are also people
who are positively living out the the
identities that they are proud of we
should give people an opportunity to to
uh articulate that if we go to the
potluck uh we go to the public metaphor
we should be welcoming people's
contributions and should we we should be
aware of the barriers to those
contributions racism anti-Semitism
islamophobia misogyny these are barriers
to people's contributions they are a
violation of the Dignity of those people
and they're also things that make the
potluck less delicious because there
mean fewer contributions that's dumb
it's dumb and it's bad right we should
be aware of those things but what we
should not do is tell people we're
having a potluck and then tell them all
the reasons that we know that they can't
bring a contribution because they're too
oppressed that's crazy that's crazy it
just it is demeaning to believe that
that it is demeaning to assume about
other people that that external forces
have so uh have so oppressed them that
they are unable to live in the world as
it is they're unable to everyone you can
bring something to the potluck that
that's a very everyone should bring
something to the public that that that's
like a pretty strong uh principle so you
worked in the Obama Administration on
the inaugural Faith Council uh you you
uh were excited about the possibilities
Trump becomes president in uh 2016 we're
going through rough times you've written
this book book in this book I highly
recommend it and I I think it's a really
important message and a well-received
message we need to build field notes for
a diverse democracy how high is your
concern level so I'm going to let you
close this on like uh
um like what are you working on now what
are you excited about how concerned are
you because even if I rewind to the
Obama years there was like this sense of
kind of optimism that I think has gone
very sharply in the other direction over
the last number of years I mean
certainly Trump's Victory got me into
politics much to my wife should grin so
uh what are you working on like what are
you excited about and how concerned are
you that we're going to end up falling
short of of our ideals so we're gonna
end up falling short of our ideals
because that that's what ideals are
right and and and this is one of the
reasons I I love religion as a model of
social change because religion is about
articulating the cosmic ideal right the
intersection of Dean and Dunya of faith
and life of the kingdom of God and then
building institutions that help
approximate that ideal and move the
world closer to it so I'm Not Afraid Of
Us Falling shorter variety deals I know
that we will I think I'm afraid of us
stopping to try you know wow and what
what am I what and I you know I love
Bill Clinton's line uh I'll quote two of
those lines one is um it's okay if I
fail
um uh uh I I I'm happy to be caught
trying I love that line right I'm happy
to be caught trying and the second was
there's nothing that's wrong with
America that what's right with America
can't fix and I believe that too right
that that somebody out there is is
solving the problem on a local level of
racial equity in in a in a health care
situation somebody out there is solving
the problem of uh uh sexism in the
corporate world
etc etc and and we need to identify
those Solutions and those leaders and
help Elevate them and scale them but I
want to answer your question directly
Andrew what what are we working on here
at Interfaith America so this book we
need to build my podcast Interfaith
America with IBU Patel we want to help
shift the social change conversation
from critics to builders we want to
shift the metaphor of diversity work in
America from melting pot and
Battleground to potluck we want to help
facilitate in the next great chapter of
American religion we think we're done
with the chapter judeo-christian it did
good work in its time it's time to move
into Interfaith America and we want to
convince people that you defeat the
things you do not love by building the
things you do and that that is a
profound opportunity to be able to build
something better it is Holy it is sacred
and we should take that opportunity and
be grateful for it Builders instead of
critics potluck instead of Melting Pot
uh and
these institutions as something that we
should be
reinforcing improving celebrating and
maybe occasionally building a new one or
two
I I thoroughly thoroughly endorse if
people want to follow you it sounds like
you have your own podcast Interfaith
America and you're on social media yep
Interfaith America with Ebu Patel and
I'm on Twitter at Ebu Patel but let's
see what happens with Twitter now that
uh now that it's in different hands in
any case I'm on it for now a lot of
people are thinking the same thing my
friend well congratulations uh on we
need to build we do indeed it's a great
achievement but it pales in comparison
to the achievement of your work uh as
someone who's been in similar types of
roles uh starting non-profit
organizations the fact that you've done
what you've done over like a
multi-decade period it takes a singular
amount of uh fortitude character
perseverance certainly Beyond me
um so uh congratulations on everything
you do alhamdulillah really praised me
to God and and don't say Beyond you
because you not only Built a non-profit
organization but then you you ran for
president and brought the message of
venture in to the National conversation
so I appreciate you and and I look
forward to the forward party Andrew and
and what's to come from you uh and I
look forward to to the next steps in our
friendship and work together genuinely
let's do it man let's build it Ebu
appreciate the heck out of you thank you